you
good evening ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to another in the series of
Reuters forms this is our sixth debate
in a series of seven debates we have
only one more to go tonight's topic is
guns and money tracking underground
funds in a borderless economy and I will
introduce our moderator after my final
invitation for the year I hope you'll
come back on may eight when we will have
our final Reuters form of the year the
topic is big brother meets big business
the future of civil liberties in an
unsafe world and we have another amazing
group of panelists but of course
tonight's discussion is going to be
especially illuminating and interesting
and it's going to be moderated by none
other than Michael Mandel who has been
moderating at the rotors form in the
past you may have seen him last year as
a matter of fact he is the economics
editor at Businessweek where he has
played a key role in defining and
popularizing the notion of the new
economy in fact for any of those who
don't like the term new economy you can
blame Michael Mandel but for a while he
was actually quite right and he keeps
coming back in popularity his 1997 cover
story the new business cycle showed for
the first time how information
technology had replaced autos and
housing as the main driving force for
the growth in the US and he wrote an
award-winning book or he's won the
gerald loeb award which in journalism is
the highest prize that a business
journalist can win and he has written a
book the coming internet depression
which also outlined how the with the
forces driving the new economy so I will
not take up any more time we've already
encroached in it i will let Michael take
over
hi there I'm just going to speak for a
couple of minutes before turning this
over to the people who know far more
about this topic of guns and money than
I do you know one of the things what I
do is I like i watch the economy both
both both domestic and international and
it's and it's and it's impossible not to
not to have your nose rubbed in the fact
and the fact just how much money is
flowing illegally across national
national borders and one of the reasons
why we know this is because when you
sort of try to so to add up the global
statistics about money crossing borders
the numbers never add up okay and you
know there's just an enormous amount of
money flowing out there and the more
globalized the economy becomes the more
money is flowing now I'm just going to
sort of give you some statistics of that
how big E's money laundering flows out
but i was told beforehand just before
this lecture that these numbers are all
worthless okay and but i'm going to give
them anyhow okay you know and the
estimates for the amount of money
laundering range anywhere you know from
300 billion up to over a trillion
dollars globally to even higher than
that these numbers are all made up
basically because nobody really knows
but it's just an enormous amount of
money funding everything from corrupt
politicians to organized crime to
terrorists to tax evaders so it's it's
it's a very big business the way that
we're going to run this is that each of
our panelists will talk for about seven
minutes and then you folks will have a
chance to ask plenty of questions
afterwards the first panelist is John
Moscow who insisted that i tell
everybody that he thought about applying
to columbia journalism school but dent
okay instead he went to law school he's
assistant district attorney and the
New York County District Attorney's
Office and he's the head of the unit
focusing on international economic crime
so give a hand to a John mask oh thank
you there's a difference between
journalists and prosecutors journalists
need information that needed to be
accurate but prosecutors need evidence
and that's a very major difference
because we have to be able to prove
something in a court of law by legally
sufficient competent evidence in the
years I've been working in the DA's
office I have been investigating all
sorts of different crimes mostly the
pathological part of business in
Manhattan securities frauds tax fraud
bank fraud all sorts of things I think
probably the best-known one was case
involving the bank of credit and
commerce international which involved 23
billion dollar bank which was committing
frauds on a daily basis all around the
world and they had a great idea they
said why should you falsify the records
when people come to investigate when you
can simply write him out false in the
first place that's how they did it and
enable them to launder money more
effectively than anybody else has ever
done it was a bank without a conscience
without any scruples that was willing to
work an equal-opportunity banker for the
Mossad Saudi intelligence KGB the CIA
the French the Argentine's the Peruvians
everybody they asked no questions I just
did what they were asked to do work very
well and going through that I learned
some lessons about how money moves how
it settles how the records are kept so
we were asked to focus on questions
Howie's
and how hard would be to choke off money
flows for terrorists what should be done
to crack down on money laundering by
terrorists and by criminals how fourth
thought would forceful action against
terrorists money flows necessarily
require Americans to lose some of their
current privacy and is this an issue we
should worry about well let me address
the last one first very quickly money is
power the ability to move money across
borders electronically means you can
exercise power from any place in the
world in any other place in the world
money laundering or anonymous use of
money means the anonymous use of power
and as you should all be aware by now
the anonymous use of power permits and
therefore predictably will necessarily
include irresponsible and abusive use of
power the quick answer is to how you can
stop that is that you can't on any one
occasion you simply can't it isn't going
to be done I know that the FBI and all
the national security people say they're
going to stop terrorism but they are not
going to do it by stopping the final
payment that pays for Obama the way you
can do it the most effective way anyway
is to focus on the infrastructure all
the terrorists groups the infrastructure
of the narcotics groups see who gets
money over time and target then you have
to do it with the understanding that any
particular payment will come through
electronic money system and not be
caught very quickly there's two trillion
seven hundred billion dollars a day in
dollars that settle every day in
Manhattan two trillion seven hundred
billion when the bank of new york had a
problem with money laundering they were
wondering 10 million a day that was 160
thousand of the 600 billion that they
a day people human beings can't find
that now this should have found it was
10 billion 10 million a day and a
residential address in Queens but that's
a different problem that was
systemically you could do it one time
you couldn't just can't do that so the
point here is that if you're trying to
target money laundering by terrorists
you have to find out who they are and
how they get paid and trace that money
the for criminals you have to you have
to have a crime first and then you trace
the money sometimes you have a complaint
you want to see if there is a crime you
trace the money and the prescription for
both of those is the same it's quite
simple and quite difficult politically
thanks and all other institutions have
to keep honest records of the flow of
funds which properly identify the people
who give the orders to move the funds
and properly identify who owns the money
at the end I say that it's very simple
Kaman doesn't agree the Swiss don't
agree a lot of other countries don't
agree and any one link in the chain and
the chain is broken the prosecutor can't
prosecute and the game is over so we
have some political problems there with
forceful action against terrorist money
flows necessarily require Americans to
lose some of their current privacy you
know you can have miss aimed forceful
blows where people come and say we're
going to take vigorous action we're
doing that now we're taking vigorous
action against a whole bunch of people
with Arabian names with dates of birth
which are random the Spelling's are
random there are multiple people with
the same names and we don't have a clue
who these people are a large number of
cases we got to list the shareholders of
a major bank that's been closed and we
tried to verify the existence and some
of them exist and some of them don't and
this is the banks copy that shareholder
list okay being forceful to those
circumstances is not going to be helpful
in dealing with finance there are three
levels of privacy one has to do with
keeping people's financial affairs from
their neighbors their friends or family
the relatives we all want that the
second level has to do with keeping it
away from law enforcement when they're
engaged in a criminal investigation when
we have that level of privacy the crooks
have the right to run free how impose to
that one the third level of privacy is
when even the bank regulators can't find
out who is getting the money and under
those circumstances the bank's owners
will tend to take the depositors money
and run has happened in Venezuela and
some other countries and that's just a
clear prescription for disaster if we
have firm controls not on privacy but
people who get access to bank records on
the police officers on the FBI and
whomever who need it for their
investigations but cannot use it for any
other purpose I believe we will be able
to maintain personal privacy and still
conduct the investigations that we need
to thank you John Moynihan partner and
founder of berg associates and I can't
say it any better than it says in the
bio he's dedicated his career to the
disruption of the surreptitious flows of
illegal proceeds through financial and
non-financial organizations which means
dealing with with with money laundering
and he says that's all he does so John
thank you Michael but those of you who
don't understand Boston speak and come
from Massachusetts oh if I don't
pronounce my eyes properly just bear
with me we don't talk very well from
Boston first of all thank you for having
it's truly an honor to be here I
regularly have the opportunity around
the world to go and speak about cases
that I'm involved with different actions
I've been involved with different
compliance initiatives that I'm involved
with with banks and brokerage houses and
businesses worldwide so it's really fun
to come to these and talk about it the
first thought I have you is what is
money laundering what exactly is it well
you can go into the codified laws and
rules and records and read a definition
but as John Moscow just alluded to it's
it's the use of unlawful proceeds the
use of those unlawful proceeds flowing
and being distributed and transported
with the purpose of hiding and
disguising the true nature and ownership
in an enemy that goes along at the use
of these monies when people use monies
that come from unlawful sources they're
attempting to engage in additional
criminal activities that will further
facilitate their pursuits one of the
phenomenons that I've recently been
involved with with regard to money
laundering is a term that I'm I'm not
coining the term but it's a term that I
see developing its convergence of
interests the convergence of interests
is traditionally separate groups
separate organized crime groups engaged
in their own levels of activities maybe
some were groups that involve typical
mafia activities here in the United
States others involved cocaine and
heroin trafficking others arm trading
and others and terrorist activities all
separate groups kind of engaging in
separate things so cases that I'm
involved with that I rather frightening
to me as a person has been doing this
and does this as a career
is the convergence of these groups one
of the issues i talked about relates to
the convergence of interests with the
exchange of monies i've been involved
with cases recently involving Middle
Eastern groups who maybe you've heard
the term hawala all it really means is a
trust network or swapping network of
monies involving trust these particular
groups using the mechanisms that they
have the relationships that they have
worldwide and in using those
relationships they need to generate
dollars and they need to generate
Tolman's and need to generate a variety
of different types of currencies to
engage in the swaps well sometimes they
get short on those monies in other words
they don't have enough one person's
delivering just for instance tomans and
the other person on the other end use
dollars delivered well if there's a
shortage of dollars where can they find
these most of these folks engagements
don't go to bank of new york or citibank
and tell them that they're involved with
the hawala they're criminals and they're
laundering money so kind of get along
that usually doesn't happen it never
happens so what's happening is I've seen
in some of the cases is these groups of
people have turned to other ethnic
groups other groups involved in other
criminal activities and those groups
have been providing funding because they
may have maybe have an excess of these
monies in the activities that deer
engage them do either willing to lend it
or actually exchange it because those
other separate groups maybe want their
money's placed in other jurisdictions so
this convergence of interest to me has
really become something of great
interest to me because I feel it's very
dangerous the danger in it is it's
creating a massive capital flow
traditionally a lot of these folks have
segmented the money kept the money
separate from one another but now as the
world has become more globalized in
internationalized so to have the
criminals followed that same sort of
strategy inning converging their
interest it creates a greater capital
flow which can create greater crimes
greater opportunities for crimes in the
use of these monies
activities I have just found for my own
personal experience and that doesn't
speak for everybody's experience it's
just mine that these groups are taking
advantage of these opportunities so to
no different than Wall Street is seeing
business opportunities economic
opportunities opportunities where they
can profit from them in convergence of
interest is an opportunity when a group
has more of a money or currency than
another group and now the group needs
that they can lend it they can
distribute it they can sell it this
massive capital flow that I've seen is
continue to grow continuing to grow and
I think that how we attack that really
is going to be very much an important
strategy for our law enforcement
agencies and for people like draw in
moscow's office and people like myself
would do a lot of compliance and a lot
of work for businesses and the
government I do a lot of contract work
for the government on money manan cases
we have to have a better global
perspective on how to attack these
things in sort of get beyond typical
race relation issues in whose black
who's white who's yellow who's read we
got to get Bobby on that because if we
want to address these issues and the
convergence of these issues we've got to
be equally as capable in getting over
these barriers to address these things I
was told to make a short speech I have
and hopefully maybe you've learned
something from it thank
our third panelist is a wolf bought the
niche to get the pronunciation right
close enough okay who is a head of
Investigations for business for York
Times a Pulitzer Prize winner a multiple
winner of prizes that are probably too
long to list I just have to say that I
have you know immense immense respect
for all the people on this panel doing
various types of investigations it's all
very difficult I know more about the
journalistic side of this and doing
investigative reporting is a very
difficult past and and he'll speak on
money laundering as well immediately
after nine eleven I was put in charge of
our coverage of tracking down terrorists
funds it has been so far the biggest
bust of the story that I have ever been
involved in probably one of the most
frustrating experiences of my journalism
career because there were such high
expectations when we got involved and
where we we figured somewhere the
government or sources or somebody would
be able to identify a big pile of money
sitting out there somewhere that clearly
funded these guys and allowed all these
horrible things to happen we're still
waiting for those stories they haven't
happened we rotated reporters in and out
of the job of covering the terrorists
and fund the tracking those down we
brought in good ones we brought in bad
ones and I wouldn't say bad ones we've
had a lot of them in there finally I
removed myself from the assignment
simply because I wanted a career at the
times and if we could start producing
big stories in that area that would not
be a good thing in thinking about what I
was going to say i should say upfront
i'm a pessimist about this about our
particularly looking at how looking back
on some of my experiences as a reporter
actually I've been thinking about what I
would say today I fought back to some of
the lessons I learned when I broke into
this business is an investigative
reporter covering two seemingly very
different beasts organized crime and
charities well actually they're a lot
more similar than than you think they're
both caste-based you know they sometimes
cheat people they hide money they
launder money but one of the first
stories I did it I from 25 years ago how
charity dollars helped bankroll the mom
now how's that for a scream in heaven
now we have here in case you can't see
it this this disabled young girl with
crutches looking up into jukeboxes and
vending machine so it's a nice collage I
don't think the times would go for that
actually but that was the Cleveland
pressing their out of business and we
had a lot of fun when I was there I
followed the money starting working on
the mob and I followed it to the mob I
mean I started working by and I followed
it to charities and what I was
interested and were the reason I brought
this in fact let me read you the first
two paragraphs of this thing three
greater cleveland charities financed by
government subsidies and public
contributions are funneling hundreds of
thousands of dollars into what state and
local authorities suspect is a mob
control of loan company the loan company
in turn is bankrolled such figures as
pornographer Larry Flynt owner hustler
magazine mafia boss Angelo big and
lonardo ex-convicts politicians blah
blah blah blah blah this could be a
template for what our coverages of
terrorists right now how charity dollars
help bankroll terrorists and that's why
I'm pessimistic because when I was
covering this field I had a great
sidekick who worked with me Walter Jones
at least to sit there and saying you
know well they say yeah Walter and say
well Walter I said you know when we turn
to a life of crime
we're going to go into the nonprofit
world and nothing i have seen has ever
shaken my belief in that that is the way
to really strike it with rich quickly
and why is that for the reasons that
these gentlemen have already laid out
there there's no documentation they have
special protections far more than from
revealing things than do banks and other
institutions so when I read the paper
today and read about how we've got all
these new regulations that are being
implemented to cover all these segments
of the industries that have never been
covered before I start thinking well you
know they're really not covering the
charities and these these nonprofit
organizations that that really reveal
nothing and and and are not forced to
reveal anything and if it's giving up
some of our freedoms or whatever which
is part of the question we've got to ask
to have these charities reveal their
financing to document all the issues
that have been raised already so that we
can track this money know what's being
done with it I'm all for it but I don't
see that happening and the reason I
don't see it happening this because of
the article that ran in the Wall Street
Journal the other day let me read you
the lead quote two weeks ago after his
agents raided the offices of several
Islamic charities and businesses
suspected of financing terrorism
Treasury secretary Paul O'Neill met with
two politically connected Muslim
activity activists who each had a tie to
the targeted group one of them a long
time Bush family associate well they got
a special audience because they're
connected and and that's what you do
when you run a charity when I run my
criminal enterprise I'm going to have on
my board lots of well-connected people
like these outfits that you know the
jukeboxes in them where the Bob Hope was
on the board and he didn't know I'm
quick hop hopes going to be going over
the records you know mayor perk you know
Cleveland and other judges and various
people I believe I'm one reason the
story has never enough rap decide one of
the reason the story is never really
developed as big as it turned out that
it really doesn't take a whole lot of
money to buy a couple of planes
tickets and take out the World Trade
Center so we're going after institutions
as we should because there are more
criminals than we want to acknowledge
and I think we're going to by throwing a
big wide net we're going to be pulling
in some some creepy people before this
is over and I think that's good but I'm
not sure that that as we're proceeding
right now that it's going to really
expose the the terrorist financing
network but maybe I could be wrong and i
hope i am questions before opening up
for questions from the floor let me ask
the panelists a question and this was
kind of going through my mind as I was
listening what's different about money
laundering today then say ten years ago
or 15 years ago and is it more worrisome
now I mean is this something you know
what you know you held up you held up
the when was that when was that article
from 1976 did I ask you how old you were
no I won't do this you know you know it
did a lot of this has been going on for
a long time so I guess the question is
what's different now and is it more
worrisome for ten years now I've been
suggesting that money laundering permits
narcotics dealers fraudsters weapons
dealers and others to conceal their
activities from law enforcement it does
not make me at all happy to find out
that I'm right I mean it's not more
worrisome it's simply that when um some
folks pay for airplane training and take
it and fly the planes into the World
Trade Center into the Pentagon or
whatever then people begin to realize
that there are in fact folks out there
who have a different view of the world
who want to destroy the one that we live
in and they aren't asking for anything
you just want to destroy it it's real
simple that's worth it and they can fund
themselves using our money transmission
facilities and they can do so without
question because the people who run
those facilities don't ask questions to
the extent
people not computers at all so basically
what we're doing is repealing back
what's been going on all this time okay
and we're sort of that this is not a new
seamy underbelly it's a it's it's
something that's been testing with us
for a long time right when the leader of
Peru cancelled a business deal with the
president of France which may generate
for somebody three hundred million
dollars in unrealized profits this was
so they could sell warplanes to Iran and
Iraq to fight a war where they were
killing each other we didn't care but it
was the same no too political leaders
took massive bribes so that they could
send weapons weapons of destruction when
they had in place embargoes this is a
problem and nobody could trace it was
totally secret we only found out about
it because we were prosecuting the
people actually negotiated the bribes
you couldn't find the records done I
think nine eleven gave us a different
perspective on a lot of these issues I
agree with both of these panelists that
it's very difficult road ahead of us and
there is no magic one that's going to
solve these things but I think the
reality is what makes it a little more
worrisome is that as John just said this
has been going on forever in Asia
Southeast Asia the Middle East the
United States Latin America South
America it's been going on everywhere
for a long time it's just now here that
we really see it it's a little bit more
overt in the accident been perpetrated
it's been going on here it's just we
haven't really seen it now we do see it
and I think that's why people a little
more worried welcome well since I've
already identified myself as a pessimist
they'll be optimistic care I'll say that
at least we're talking about it and we
have people covering it we have people
writing about it and we're making some
effort to raise everyone's consciousness
maybe that's the first step towards I
mean certainly not eliminating this this
behavior but maybe at least stopping
some of it let me just do a follow up
there you know we have ostensibly in
countries that had bank secrecy laws are
loosening up on them a bit ostensibly
you sort of you know the the new rules
that have put in at least put some onus
on more financial institutions to sort
of do reporting okay is this going to
make any difference it will make a lot
of difference for some crimes but as I
said before it's not going to make any
difference for specific payoffs for
specific terrorist activities those
cannot be stopped there's no one time
deal to get caught I'm going to open
this up to questions from the audience I
didn't need to ask two things one is
that when you ask the question you
identify yourself and the second thing
that I ask is that when you ask the
question then you actually ask the
question okay and not I mean if you
start giving a speech LOL ask you to ask
the question okay yes JD want to cut
with Brewer college my question is for
mr. Moynahan you talked about the
growing trend of the convergence between
the terrorist groups and traditional
organized crime how do we deal with the
blowing of those lines and what should
the Treasury Department be doing
differently well I think what happens is
first off I don't know i don't have the
strategy number one but i think there
needs to be the employment of some
forward thinking about how this
globalization of this financing works
how is it that these groups are coming
together in why are they coming together
as opposed to just a band-aid approach
of let's go round up all the Arabs and
Jewish guys in IRA guys and round them
all up which will do nothing we better
figure out why these people are doing
what
doing and if we understand a little bit
more about why they're doing then it's
then it's almost like a linear equation
algorithm a mathematical album you might
have the opportunity to predict what
might be happening it'll be a little bit
more forward thinking there is no magic
wand but they better do some study
before they decide how they're going to
fix it hi my name is Ben I'm an
undergrad here at Columbia this question
is for any of the panelists how much do
we know about the the nature of the
money laundering for these rogue groups
I mean generally is it a few centers of
large sums of money or as a network of
smaller songs and if it is a network of
smaller songs if ten million dollars a
day at the bank in York goes unnoticed
what's the what's the precedent for
catching them in the process is there
any kind of software analysis that we
can run on different capital flows or
something like that that would make this
easier or is it just trial and error let
me try to address this the need is for
intelligence so that when you see that
money has flowed you know what it means
the amounts of money that the Saudi
charities received work publicly
reported and they are using them
hypothetically to bring kids out into
the great outdoors to get some order in
their lives to learn how to do athletic
feats right well the difference between
that and military training is zero okay
so just understand that this charity
could just divert some of its training
to sending pic know some of the athletic
feats maybe shooting they may be some of
the mechanical things maybe building
bombs reading the words on paper doesn't
tell you what the charity is doing and
no one is going to go in there as part
of a money laundering enterprise to see
how a charity is spending its money so
it's the money laundering portion of it
is true
compared to the need for intelligence
and I I can't say any more than that we
can't trace the sums because all will
see is that the money is going to a
charity being spent by the charity as it
says everybody else part of just me well
I mean we've just like everyone else
speculated informed speculation i should
point on and our pages is to wear a lot
of this is coming from I mean we
reported on honey stores around there
that somehow there and we would report
it on just about everything I said all
the other papers you know it's charities
it's this outlet it's the wallows it's
that we really don't know and and we're
looking at them all so I wish I could be
more definitive than our government is
but I can't pack a suit room college how
much of fat does American policy have on
who's investigated and who is not
investigating it seems like some
organizations like the IRA perhaps group
sympathetic to the United States can do
what they want to when other groups
certain Mideast groups might get closer
scrutiny because their policies don't
agree with Americans
clearly there are groups which are
subject to law enforcement interest in
different countries which get
investigated and the British have a very
very comprehensive investigation of the
IRA the Americans for many years we're
looking at things like Hezbollah but not
looking at Saudi charities that's
changed no one can look at everything
and I'm not I mean obviously you're
going to be looking at the areas where
terrorists are causing Terra in your own
country what's happened after September
11th is the national anti terror
organizations are sharing information
and so I think in that sense we're
better off now than we've ever been but
of course I mean if you want I think
it's just the wrong way to look at it to
say the nation's policy is that have
been look at the groups that are hostile
and not the ones that are friendly of
course that's true I mean if you're
talking about terrorists you're going to
look at the guys who throwing the bombs
they are the first and foremost targets
breach in every country even if the
groups are different in different
countries and just add that you know
age-old problem is 11 persons terrorist
is another's freedom fighter and when
the Kosovo Liberation Army was raising
money to commit some terrorist acts that
was a good thing in the view of American
policymakers and others because they
were pursuing a just cause so so we're
told now you know that my others might
have a different point of view
particularly those on you know the
receiving end of you know whatever
terrorist activity or freedom fighting
activities has occurred so certainly
that's very shadowy area and one that's
very difficult to you know if you're
going to track terrorists who are the
terrorists and who are the noble
fighters that they're seeking liberation
of there
I mean tough one I'd like to just throw
a thought in that light to like another
part of that also is the practicalities
of investigating these crimes there's
cross jurisdiction amongst many agencies
to investigate drug trafficking or
kidnapping or what have you if you just
think about how big America is there's
federal state and local authorities if
you took one address out here in Queens
or in Manhattan there's the possibility
that a police group from Seattle it came
up in there at that case someone had
seen Diego that might have been a state
agency someone in Boston it might have
been a federal agency with it all of a
sudden you've got all these interests in
this one address in Manhattan who's
taking the lead just thinking about that
the practicalities of investigating
these crimes it gets very good shut the
phone off someone's calling for more
money laundering the practicalities of
it are very difficult to deal with and
that gets a little bit even beyond the
policies who's going to do the work my
name is Jim Garst the question is
addressed to both mr. Barnett Moynihan
and mr. buck damage and it's not
directly on terrorism but I think it's a
myth in the writers forum ballpark it
has to do with something growing out of
what we're hearing today which would
involve something called the Tobin tax
I'm assuming that many people know that
that is a proposal by a economist James
Tobin to put a very small percentage tax
on international exchanges and the
difficulties we've heard today about
tracing money and laundering money in
terms of its ultimate sources terrorist
activity would also seem to apply to the
administration of terror of the Tobin
tax
which has been argued is easily
administered because the clearance
mechanism is highly centralized well I'm
just trying to lay a basis here for
people who might think this is a little
off kilter if it is so difficult to
detect international flows going to
terrorism wouldn't it be equally
difficult and impractical to administer
a Tobin tax I guess I'm not qualified to
answer that I wish I I was qualified but
I really don't have a clue I'll be
called I I'll actually answered that
because I'm it's just as the sort of
visit okay well you go ahead you've
actually hit on a very interesting part
of the money laundering world
particularly as it relates to the
movement and transportation of goods
maybe you've read in The Times or
business week or something to something
that their fridge was the black market
peso exchange of money and it involves
the sale of goods say leaving the United
States into South America and the people
who actually purchase those goes to
distributors and resell them down there
they don't pay tax they smuggle the
goods in the reason is because those
Goods the taxes and tariffs on those
goods maybe thirty or forty percent very
high well if you're a smuggler and this
goes on with many American companies I'm
very involved with and compliance things
and investigations if you're selling to
a distributor who is a smuggler who
doesn't want to pay tax that same
distribute is not going to the bank for
a letter of credit and alone and telling
the bank there is a smuggler because the
underwriting that's not going to happen
so when you address the issue of taxing
exchanges of money one of the big
impetuses for why people want the money
is to avoid taxes they do it to avoid
taxes so you could you can put a Tobin
tax on whatever you want it's not going
to affect the people in the underground
because they're not report in the first
place so this may actually grow
possibilities to make grow
the illegal capital flow not reduce it
yes my name is Kelvin Kelvin kizito ki
ng from baruch college have a couple of
questions the first question is a twenty
members of the panel is there any study
or you're aware of any study that shows
any negative impact of money laundering
and the economy with positive or
negative impact and the second question
is to do with globalization is it that
the current global era has enhanced
money laundering or money laundering as
enhanced globalization Jan you haven't
spoken for a while so I'll try the
second one I think that the as the
technology that permits the flow of
money has changed so that you can now
move money from your sip with your cell
phone to a modem on your personal
computer to your bank account to through
the electronic fund transfer systems you
can move money anywhere in the world
from anywhere in the world so long as
it's in dollars at least pretty much in
pounds the technology now is so advanced
that money laundering is a lot easier
than it was 20 years ago cayman has not
been around that long and they did not
have the facilities that they're
developing new york could not have the
facilities in his built the technology
is driving that rest the question i'm
not going to touch
go ahead I'm actually involved in a case
right now with that question has arisen
and the issue is from a damaged
perspective what are the macroeconomic
effects of money laundering on an
economy and there have been a number of
studies done we actually I actually
could refer you to a book I don't have
it with me right now if it's maybe 52 or
53 different articles on this subject
that I've been researching but one of
the interesting thoughts that I've seen
in several of these has been the effects
on a country's currency given the
development of crime in whether that
property which is owned by the
government whether that property is
negatively impacted to damage assessment
a property assessment by the development
of crime if you take for instance a
place like Columbia the world's largest
producer of cocaine if you look at as
production levels increased there's been
a significant decrease in the value of
that currency so those are some studies
that I've read about and I don't know if
they're accurate or not but people are
researching them yeah the studies I'll
show that that increased corruption is
bad for growth but they're all kind of
squishy and in some sense they don't
tell you anything more then common sense
will tell you which is that if a country
gets a reputation for money laundering
and corruption that it will actually
deter a more reputable more reputable
business aunt Annie and I'm a student
the School of International public
affairs at Columbia University and my
question goes to mr. Moscow and I wanted
to know would you like to see us laws
change its so how would you like to see
it US laws change to make your
prosecution investigation admission into
evidence easier or do you feel more
inhibited by the lack of international
jurisdiction and enforcement
the the USA patriot act passed in
October very expeditiously not to say
hastily it makes some major changes in
how banking is going to have to be
conducted in the United States I don't
know that we need a change in laws we
have one in New York which outlaws money
laundering as defined which and they
define it basically to move money
through the money or security settlement
facilities in New York if that money is
the result of a crime committed that
would have been a crime in New York
you've committed here or that was
committed here but it need not have been
committed here it can be committed
anywhere in the world I'm not a pig
that's pretty good statute so between
that and the USA PATRIOT Act which
appears to require correspondent banks
to appoint agents for the service of
process so that the bank records can be
compelled to be produced here if two
trillion seven hundred billion generates
more cases than we can handle now and
the new tools are going to bury us the
question is um do we need new laws no I
don't think so i think we need to use
the ones that we have but don't think we
need new ones so you need more money for
enforcement could you use more money
always what the problem really is that
the cases require a large number of
sophisticated people and when people
talk about the threat to individual
liberty involved in all this the quick
answer is don't worry about it aren't
that many people doing it does that mean
you only end up focusing on the biggest
cases or on what I mean what's the know
it serendipity plays a very large part
yes hi my name is sarita I'm from Brook
college I was just wondering what are
the possibilities of this terrorist
group or crime groups to transfer their
money abroad maybe to the United States
not through technology but through our
US ports do you have any specific device
to scan what's inside those large
containers and we have enough manpower
to find out what's inside those
containers and my last question is if
you do catch those crooks what are you
going to do with the money I used to
work in de but I definitely want to hear
Walton John's perspective on it first
off there aren't enough people to run
enough tools I read a report last year
that over 66 million dollars within
every 25 days cycle is transported in
bulk currency through Miami
International Airport I mean it's all
heading south the bottom line is who's
going to stop this how many people do
you want to employ to do this in here's
the reality if you put a hundred agents
200 agents 500 news reporters a thousand
people at Miami International Airport
they're going to go to New York they're
going to go to Seattle these people are
good they're smart they're sophisticated
and as John said I agree changing the
laws really that's not the issue the
issue is people need to change their
behavior and just recognize that you
know we're living in a society here and
we're all supposed to be in this
together in if you don't want to do that
then you know what it's never going to
end that's just the reality of it it's
going to go on in perpetuity but we
certainly don't have all the tools
you want to add something what I guess
we alternate don't we okay Valentina's
take is from your college my question is
how much government's with their
policies push industries and activities
into underground economy for example by
imposing sanctions on certain countries
they porsche and regard round activities
not just in that country but also in
other countries yeah so the question was
how much the government policies force
force activities underground that could
have been done otherwise legally some
whether it's sanctions or in terms of
international money laundering I'm not
doing a gun smuggling any kind of
underground economy because you can see
that in the countries that are under the
sanctions usually you can see products
from other countries that impose these
sanctions oh that's a smuggling in
countries where people want to fight a
war and want to buy weapons they will do
so the Western democracies will impose
sanctions and pompous other salesmen
have to sell the weapons that's been the
history of the last 25 years at least
the sanctions do not cause it and they
do not stop it the era should for
whatever reasons but the weapon sales go
on to the extent that we have largely a
fella named Cardone who was selling
cluster bombs out of chili to the Iraqis
to use against the Iranians the only
thing is those cluster bombs were made
only in the United States until we gave
them the means to do it there was that
money being wondered take take your
guess and then economist of the
Reserve Bank notice that the United
States was shipping to Iraq 31 million
dozen eggs which came out to two dozen
for each man woman and child in the
country The Economist one want to know
why and finally aha here's 31 million
dozen eggs for a rack and please don't
shoot them at us now who is laundering
that that was part of our government's
policy David quincel Columbia life long
learner all three of you gentlemen have
emphasized several times how difficult
it is to taste the flow of money and to
collect pertinent data to be able to get
a handle on what indeed is happening now
when you say difficult is it difficult
because it's a difficult or is it
difficult because the appropriate
international institutions or
governments that possess certain
resources which will be highly valuable
in the kind of security of confronting
simply are not sufficiently interested
so if usually motivated they have not
been sufficiently adversely affected to
to want to move in with measures of such
magnitude that it blows your mind it's a
good question well I tell you I can only
speak from experience I give you an
example I was involved in some of the
different work on this Bank of New York
situation some of the transactions to
give you example
were Russian organized crime groups who
went to an island called Naru right they
go to Naru which is about this big many
of the law firms that set up the
offshore companies in that room I'm from
Naru they have exclusive arrangements
these law firms may be from Panama maybe
from other countries blah blah blah they
go there and open up offshore
corporations to initiate wire transfers
that go from NAIRU to grease the st.
Petersburg Russia to France how as mr.
Moscow said how are you possibly going
to collect information to trace those
transmitters all the way through to say
that the illegal money that went tonight
will when degrees to went to Russia
there's no cooperation there's no one to
answer the phone and neither to get the
first piece of paper but when you look
at the fedwire system that accounts for
it you can see where it came from but
there's no way to get the information
but that's the problem with God last but
John let me just extend it a little bit
further suppose that we were just sort
of say you know we don't think there's
any reputable business in narrow okay
which I know and I would and when I was
preparing for last week class there's
nobody there's no there's no industry
there there's no people there it's a
little speck as opposed that you were to
sort of say okay we're just not going to
accept any wire transfers from there and
is that a matter of will okay if there
was enough will and resources okay we
did that with Naru through eight
thousand people they used to have a
whole lot of bird droppings and they
sold back stuff for fertilizer banana
without their bird dropping so they're
trying to become an international
financial centre and Iroh has been in
fact cut off from the world financial
system because the major industrial
countries just got fed up after the bank
of new york case where the Russians have
never been to Nauru the Australian
lawyers have never been there no one had
it was ridiculous but take the company
take the
different situation in Antigua where the
Russians moved in took over the banks
and the trip the State Department tried
to impose sanctions on Antigua the ante
Qin bankers started to make serious
hired a lobbyist who was involved in
Texas Bankers Association he went to
phil gramm was chairman senate banking
and bingo he didn't get any AP money
laundering legislation you can get any
support for the fight against antigua
and you had all totally corrupt banking
system where the US was stymied because
they lobbied the senator in charge of
the Banking Committee but but that's
actually but that's the best kind of the
point yeah what I wanted to address in
addition with John just said is we have
to remember we hold ourselves out as the
epicenter for capitalism entrepreneurial
ism here in the United States freedom to
do business if the Bank of New York
isn't going to earn the twenty dollars
on a wire transfer fee at the clip John
was talking about somebody else is gonna
earn it because there's a lot of coin to
be made in those transfers someone's
going to pick up the slack and that's
the problem much of what we promote
ourselves are as capitalists and
entrepreneurs the bad guys are just
mimicking well we're holding ourselves
up to be so someone else is going to
pick up those fees but let me ask you a
question they're coming along the same
line if we had a global financial system
it for some if by some imagine a world
where we could extend the US financial
regulation globally okay is that a world
in which money laundering on this scale
would still exist or wood is a purely
hypothetical question but it goes to the
Costa kinda question of is this a kind
of a technological problem that sort of
connected with the nature of financial
systems or is this a is this a political
problem when I'm kind of hearing is that
to a large extent it's a it's a
political you know it's a political
problem
my point of view if the United States
work if the area is covered by the
dollar the only areas that were relevant
the problems would still be the same
money is laundered now by using secret
corporations trusts and so on as a
prosecutor I need to be able to prove
who gave the orders and who got the
money and if those are the facts which
are concealed the fact that i can see
that the money went into an account and
out well who did it sorry that's the
secret fact come on that is it it's
silly we just we're spinning our wheels
now I don't think that there is the put
at the wheel yet to end that kind of
secrecy but that's where they push it
yeah we'll see okay yes and my name is
Leland landris I'm a graduate student of
journalism here at Columbia from the
different everybody's instead of
relatively pessimistic view as do I
concerning how to limit this that it's
an uphill battle that it's so widespread
it's also widespread here it doesn't
seem necessarily extremely difficult to
launder money and i look at the movie
industry in LA it's very very inherent
if this is basically an impossible fight
and you have blind borders in a way
where let's say i have friend to come
from foreign countries to study here and
they have to go take a bank account
statement to the bank and they say yeah
yeah but we're not worried because our
bank will always say that we have money
in the account you have instantaneous
transactions over internet you can do
thousands of them it wasn't like you had
to take a bunch of money to the bank and
deposit
so what does the United States
government or the current administration
is it understood the level of the fight
and is there going to be a shift in
where they're going to fight the fight
instead of putting all their resources
in a place that's in the very difficult
are they going to shift it well the
solutions obviously to hire thousand
more investigative reporters will get to
the bottom of it we want these guys do
their best and one what if they don't
know just want to me I don't know I I
mean I i'm not sure exactly what the
question is did instead of saying we're
going to find out where the money came
from and there's like hundreds of
thousands of small cash transactions
which is impossible to trace and it's
hard to trace a 10 million dollar a day
transaction so you change the focus you
change it to where how these companies
how these countries and different groups
are into networking instead of chasing
the money which is it changes all the
time that's the thing that I think John
will probably jumping in it's so
flexible the ability to learn the money
the permutations on it a limitless
that's the difficulty with that you can
do the cases you can do you can try to
create the Terrance people need to
change the behavior if they don't the
permutations
I was what was the behavior change what
was the what's the policy change where
does the government go now that's my
point you could change any policy you
wanted but that just means that maybe
someone's going to alter their behavior
and do something different Chuck honey
do you want to hit just you've got to
get intelligence about who's committing
which crimes and then you can try to
trace backwards from them to the money
but and then you can use the money to
prove the case in the court of law but
if you simply try to look at the flow of
money through the federal reserve system
you will never ever be able to do it
there's much too much going much too
fast and the globe does not have a
capacity to analyze the transactions
that are taking place the rate of two
trillion 700 billion a day we can't do
it The Wall Street Journal just recently
wrote a story about one of the Islamic
banks that has been sort of effectively
shut down out of business and they found
that all the eight the money transfers
were still continuing that just
different agents doing it in the same
locations they were in this case
mcdonough's you know and and they just
take another form and so here you had a
strong decisive blow against this bank
that really ended up just putting
certain people off moving certain people
off the stage and others moved moved on
to take their place another point on
that also what when they have policies
about sanctions let's say we're going to
sanction Russia for what's going on with
the banking system because it's so
horrible well if you're dkb bank in
Russia maybe you go to Greece you open
up a correspondent account Greece helps
you open an account in France who clears
its payments to the United States
central banking system correspondent
banking that's the problem how are you
going to get the information that that
DK be in Russia is doing banking
increase how are you going to know that
that's what these organizations do
questions it was re re leaving with
Farouk college for the last few months
we've all seen advertisements that have
basically been telling us for telling
kids that when they buy drugs they're
putting hands and the money of
terrorists aside from seeming like
really bad advertising because I don't
know anyone who's used drugs that cares
about where the money goes in the end it
also just seems like problematic logic I
mean they're not connecting the dots for
us they make us do it ourselves and you
don't I mean it makes a little bit of
sense with the convergence theory but
it's still I feel like there's a wide
array of knowledge that needs to be
filled you know ever since the just say
no program and did I see drugs rooster
drug is just skyrocketing the just when
John was talking about the convergence
of interests I was just writing down
some notes because he's absolutely dead
right the Colombians have a whole lot of
cash that they get from selling cocaine
here the Russians we're selling out the
country of wire transfers but they
needed cash back in Russia to distribute
to the real owners which is something it
took us many years to realize that then
we there were laundering money in the
opposite direction where the two of them
got together things got really bad now
with the collapse of the Soviet Union
you have a lot of Muslim countries that
are near Afghanistan Pakistan and so on
which are perfectly willing now when
they were not before to permit the
transportation of heroin so the heroin
problem in Europe is going up like a
skyrocket those are the same folks in
Afghanistan who have been Afghanistan
for a while the funding of I don't know
if it's the terrorists or not I really
do not have a breakdown on who is whom
in Afghanistan but we do know that the
heroin that's grown there is now
coming through Russia and there there
was a wonderful little story little k
heading the times about the boat being
arrested off the Azores for the crew of
Russians Ukraine's and Colombians and a
load of cocaine and heroin that's the
problem okay the heroin is coming from
areas which are sort of hostile to the
United States right now the cocaine is
coming from people who are learning
being taught by the IRA had to engage in
terror in Colombia I'm not sure the end
even if it doesn't give the information
is necessarily wrong question my name is
Carolyn Shuang your student at the joy
ISM school money launderers need to find
new ways to launder the money as a
facial services industries coming under
more and more regulation and they may
turn towards the art market casinos the
set of precious stones I was wondering
whether you could already see signs of
this displacement in the channels money
launderers used to rounded their money
and how can what can you do to fight
that I'm not sure this displacement
because I've been told for many years
that those channels have been used the
only three or four guys I know who can
trace the laundering of money to the art
world are busy and there's a lot more
work right we just don't have the people
and this is this is now maybe if we
started putting up ads among the art
department say we want art majors to
come and start prosecuting money
laundering cases we can get it but we
haven't done that yet and we really
don't have the people if you look
historically if you do LexisNexis chess
check on money laundering and gold
mining diamonds you'll be reading for
the next you know year on these cases
it's been going on for a long time it's
just as John says how many cases can we
do with the resources we have it's going
on it has been going on we call it
displacement it's kind of false very
prophylactic it to help us think we know
what's going on the reality is it's been
going on a long time will just happen to
see it now now I have this up listening
to side this picture of sort of you know
water coming down okay it just kind of
running right through the hands you know
you're catching a little bit in your in
your palm and everything else is just
going right through glad to see we're
being lucid okay yeah your message is
getting through I thing go ahead this is
Nick Fulton from Reuters I have a
question regarding drug into the drug
business if we were to change the whole
thats a governmental international
stance on drugs and to see it as
something the government should just see
as a taxable entity and then allow the
money to flow through the system in a
legitimate way the taxing if it was kept
at the right level would probably call a
huge quantity of money to governments
that they can then put into reducing the
need of drugs which would bring the
drugs into it a world of of proper
finance where the money flows get
trapped now presumably the people doing
the production are paying enormous
quantities to move money around and if
the tax levels were set below the cost
of doing illegal drug smuggling then
they would merely start to compete to
produce the cost would go down and in
the end of thing could get eradicated
that seems to be one of the major
sources of this illegal money to support
terrorism do you have any comments on on
master proposal I know I of course your
comments on that the reality is there's
a couple of guys I'd love to bring up
here and sit down and in to that
question they're doing 25 years since
right now 2,000 kilos of cocaine and it
actually asked these guys this question
and both of them had the same response
very business-like response market share
if you think anybody is going to want to
work at Johnson & Johnson
pharmaceuticals or Kendall when you when
they try to take over our market share
you saw planes hit those buildings down
there wait here wants machine guns and
they both told me mow down people and
parking lots because you're taken over
our market share very scary responses
these are guys who've committed multiple
murders have no conscience and they just
it's almost a very stoic business
approach to it that that's those guys
other guys will say go ahead legalize it
we're just going to make something else
we're going to make something else
because you're not going to take our
money away from us the reality you won't
get the money away from these people you
can legalize it and maybe you address
one drug but good be another one I mean
that's just the way they think you know
just to follow up and this is not a
professional thing but there is an
alternative to their killing the people
of johnson and johnson which is the use
of money to buy Johnson & Johnson and
then they can set the moral tone for the
United States and for its Congress and I
just put to you the question is that the
world you want to live in where people
who think it appropriate to submachine
gun folks but decide it's cheaper to buy
the company do that I think that with
that without being too optimistic about
the moral tone the American business
community in Enron era I think you are
you're really in the wrong league okay
there are worse people yes over there
private sheriff in journalism school I
have a question for mr. Moscow mr.
Moynahan what percentage of money
laundering do you think actually comes
out of legal channels to avoid taxation
rather than illegal channels to try to
get back into legitimate business any
guesses on that all in this country well
first off taxation avoidance is not a
predicate crime for money laundering
charge number one so you
just be avoiding your taxes and then in
so doing that crime then you can get
with a mile on in charge that that's not
the way it works legally and John would
probably able to address that better
than me but crimes other than that fraud
drug trafficking or what have you those
are what they call predicate crimes
specified unlawful activities that then
you can get charged with money money
when you move the revenue associated
with that I would approach it
differently I would say there may be
crimes of money laundering which can be
violated but it can simply focus on the
purpose of the money-laundering statutes
which are when I want to prosecute
somebody for a substantive crime it's
because and I can't because the evidence
has been concealed it is that which I'm
referring to its money laundering and
the the problem is we have crimes now
called money laundering which don't
address that as directly as they might
like so that there's some ambiguity but
if you are simply focusing on
old-fashioned classic crimes money
laundering is the process by which you
conceal the evidence so the perpetrators
the crime can't be prosecuted
successfully and if you use that
definition than your question misses the
point well whatever it was how would you
what you call bloody lottery concealing
profits in from the corporation from the
corporate side as opposed to just hiding
profits from the illegal side when you
say concealing profits do you mean that
the president the corporation sets up a
phony consulting company offshore pays
it money and then has the money
transferred to his account is that
concealing profits or is that stealing
from the corporation I don't know thanks
but it'll be a quiz after class okay
we're going to take one more question
here kind of simple one for you I'm a
private businessman I used to
of the partner of estoppel gnosis as a
result to hear a lot to see a lot and
just what the college said it's
interesting I have a question for mr.
Moscow mr. Monaghan but Bogdanovich is
out of this situation because you ever
think of putting up a bounty and getting
real into it and saying what's the boys
moving in mail billion I'll cut you in
for 250 to 500 if you help us find them
good question well actually there are
bounties that go up they don't advertise
them dyed yellow appetizer nothing else
about but but there's a lot of people
who work as informants no but you dr.
Welling they work down there on Wall
Street they work in big corporations and
they get paid big monies to help find
these people except for one thing it was
Wall Street that actually helped Enron
do what it did and I say yeah real
estate agent said to me on a bus
recently well I got it that was the best
thing that ever happened our money is
being switched to real estate we don't
trust Wall Street I go back to this you
don't advertise it what I I've seen a
lot of guys okay yeah guns or will ever
talk will advertise the bounties next
but the question is why don't you
advertise it
I don't know I mean maybe unikey would
take place there's so much crime help
and maybe everybody would sign up to you
know go after it you know okay on that
on that note I liked a big hand to our
panelists here they were